can I have a kiss no I've had a guitar
face what are you doing this is actually
very accurate representation of my
morning's day of Hana and most of you
know me as the world's okay us mom but
many of you probably don't know that I
am a full-time working mom as a tasty
producer mornings in my house are pure
chaos
so usually I'm the last one to get
dressed in the morning wait where did
you get that oh my gosh I'm so sorry
okay okay in the morning I get to pick
one thing to do for myself it's either
pick a nice outfit or do my makeup and
skin routine or do my hair there's not
time for all three what are you guys
doing get careful oh my god we I get to
get ready by myself oh my god I cannot
remember the last time I got ready alone
oh my gosh I love my kids but I am going
to take advantage of every second of
this morning oh my gosh somebody cleaned
my bathroom this is like a spa so I'm
gonna start with my skincare routine I
use Olli wipes because I very dry skin
and I need a moisturizer under my makeup
they don't have like 15 minutes to wait
for it to soak in and this is a really
light and airy one that's soaks in right
away and I can go straight into my
makeup routine growing up I had really
easy just amazing skin and so I was like
who needs moisturizer and then I had kid
and now my skin is just suddenly super
dry it's been a journey finding a
skincare routine that's quick and just
something that's easy and not
over-the-top for me I've always wanted
blue hair my mom never allowed me to
really do much with my hair and then
when I had kids I figured you know
that's kind of it for me I thought it
was like maybe a little inappropriate
for me to do it or maybe it was too
young for me to try then after I had
kids and I started working full-time I
was struggling to find time for myself
and do things for myself without my
confidence
was kind of plummeting and so one day I
was like you know what I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna do blue hair because I know
it's gonna make me happy and I did it
about two years ago and I haven't
changed you back alright it's time to
pick something to wear I think that my
style didn't develop until I became a
mom I stopped caring so much about what
other people thought it was just you
what do I need what do I like so I
definitely have some really embarrassing
throwback photos of when I tried to be
trendy and you can just tell them the
photos that it's so not me usually in
the morning I'm getting dressed because
I'm doing drop-offs drop-offs for school
are surprisingly messy one kid wipes his
mouth on my outfit at least once a day
so since I'm not doing drop-offs way
back in my closet there's this one dress
I've never worn it because I've never
really had the occasion to wear it I'm
gonna dig deep and I think I'm gonna
wear this dress today I am so ready for
my tasty shoot let's go
I feel like today went the best it
possibly could have a caiman super
confident I was feeling really relaxed
people were coming up to me all day
saying that I looked really nice and
just having that time this morning to
clear my head I think just helped me
totally rock my shoot today oh my gosh I
missed you so much
today was incredible but I have to be
honest hanging out on the couch with my
kids in a t-shirt and sweats is just the
best
[Music]